hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my full guardians of the galaxy to
review so when I do get to spoilers I'll
just say spoiler warning so here we go
most of you have probably already seen
the movie but it's dropping this week in
America so I'm going to do is a giveaway
for IMAX tickets all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video so I've had the chance to
see the movie at least once more since I
posted my non-spoilery review they're
really only a couple things that I've
changed my opinion on but I'll still say
that James Gunn is probably one of the
best it's not the best filmmaker single
filmmaker because the Russos are two
people in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
right now now there are a couple new
directors that are dropping like Tiger
would t be is going to be doing Thor
Ragnarok later this year we haven't seen
any of his Marvel films before so you
can't really judge him yet but James
Gunn is so good at what he does that he
is now sort of like the overseer of
Marvel's cosmic universe if you're not
already excited for guardians 3 based on
some of the post-credits scenes what
they said is the guardians 3 is going to
set up the next 10 years of Marvel
cosmic films he is the de-facto Living
Tribunal of the Marvel Universe so
there's all kinds of cosmic things that
he teased that they're going to be
developing what other species we'll be
seeing but as I talked about some of the
characters and some of the issues I had
with the way it used the villains like
the sovereign we'll talk about the
current state of Marvel's cosmic races
but overall the film was amazing
definitely go see it in theaters it
wasn't quite able to capture the magic
of the first film the sense of discovery
because in that first film everything
was new and they went super weird and in
an attempt to not recycle everything
very formulaic Lee he tried to be very
different with where he took the sequel
try to keep it very self-contained but I
feel like a few of those choices limited
the film a little bit and there were a
couple complaints that I had with
over-reliance on certain types of humor
certain bits that just went on
too long but the character work was
amazing so comparing it to the first
film the characters were much better the
villains were a little bit better -
ronan from the first film suffered from
a lot of those Marvel underdeveloped
villain problems that's been a common
problem for the MCU they're slowly
moving away from that I think Stannis is
probably going to be the best example
that maybe the Black Panther villains
like Kilgore
even Michael Keaton's vulture character
and spider-man homecoming maybe they'll
break that cycle because they are some
grade-a actors and Kate Blanchette is
going to be an amazing villain so
Elizabeth to Vicki as a Yesha was a
great character but there just wasn't a
whole lot of her they teased her at the
end of the movies going to be a much
bigger thing in Guardians 3 so I will be
doing separate post credit videos later
this week after everybody has a chance
to see the movie because there's a whole
bunch of stuff that happens during them
some of them are way more important than
others especially the ones that are
relevant to yondu's character so we'll
start with yondu yondu had the best arc
in the film he was the best character
and I've already said a lot about how
the character found his way into the
first Guardians film it was a very
roundabout way he wasn't originally
intended to be part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but now he sets up
this huge arc that's going to continue
in other Marvel movies so you talk about
Sylvester Stallone's character in those
Easter eggs they'll continue to be big
characters in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe they've already said that even
if they don't show up in the third
guardians film they will show up in
other Marvel films you know maybe the
Thor franchise just because they're
cosmic but because there are so many
unknown questions about what kind of
movies are going to do in phase 4 and
which other franchises are going to get
a third or fourth movie we just don't
know which movie exactly they're going
to pop up in they're talking about
backstories so that's all related to
yondu's backstory they teased this grand
history of the Marvel cosmic universe a
lot of things that the guardians are
experiencing the trouble that they're
having inside their family sort of the
infighting happened before with yondu
and a bunch of his friends so I love the
way that they weave in all this new ego
the Living Planet story to the yondu's
story as well as Peter Quill's history
at the same time so you learn a lot
about his character the history of the
Marvel Universe in celestial constructs
so in that way the movie is very big
while at the same time being very small
so when people say it's a small movie
the biggest complaint I've seen by far
is that there's very little plot that's
not wrong the characters do a lot of
things but when you look at it from a
bigger perspective really not a lot
happens in the film and then then
meeting up with ego the Living Planet in
the big revelation about what his
storyline is so really that's about it
so it's not like they're teasing big
infinity war stuff which I think a lot
of people expected because Thanos was in
the first movie so if there's anything
that
failed to deliver on it was like big
universe changing things even though I
thought it did a very good job of
introducing very big concepts in the
Marvel Universe we haven't learned a lot
about the Celestials there was the
collector that teased the infinity gems
that was a big reveal there's not really
anything on that level in this movie
there are a couple big character reveals
that I thought were well used which I
will explain in one of my post credit
scene videos but the other big setup for
the new character that you've been
waiting for this whole time at the end
so major bonus points for doing all the
things that you thought they were not
going to do like if you remember comic
book fans complaining because hey
where's Adam warlock where are all these
other characters what's going on this
looks so different from the comics James
Gunn has so much comic-book stuff in
this movie but some of its done in such
a subtle ways that you don't most miss
it if you weren't a huge comic book fan
and looking for those things in most of
the problems the film has I think are
largely due to the first film just being
so magical and so fresh like oh my god
this looks so different from all these
other Marvel films this is amazing so
the benchmark is just way too high you
can do really weird stuff and they do
ego the Living Planet is so weird in
this movie I love it and they are
relatively true to his origin story even
though technically he's not a celestial
in the comics is closer to being one of
the elders of the universe but usually
those aren't things that I complain
about I didn't even think that they were
going to do Adam warlock in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and now they're like
oh yeah we're definitely going to do him
after guardians 3 he is totally a thing
most of the complaints you hear about
the film this week will probably be
about the humor the Drax character is
totally interesting but I feel like once
you get more into his backstory start
talking about moon dragon his daughter
I think it'll get way better but they
definitely over rely on him for some
humor that just does not land so I
totally forgive him for it but I feel
like the big surprise was that baby
Groot works so well you'd think it'd be
super cringy but he was actually a
pretty amazing part of the film but I'll
go ahead and say careful for spoilers as
we get into like the last part of the
video I'll be a little bit more specific
about the things that I like things I
didn't like
in Vin Diesel has been teasing that you
have not seen full blown Groot yet even
though he was an adult in the first film
they're like you have not seen Groot
Unchained so just to explain the
timeline a little bit from this film to
infinity war there's going to be about
four
years that passed between the end of
guardians to in the beginning of
infinity war so there was any question
that just implying that baby group will
be full-blown group by the time we get
to Thanos Infinity Gauntlet but Chris
Pratt Zoe Saldana Dave Bautista Karen
Gillan even Sean Gunn is crackling the
ravager really all the Ravagers
everybody was fantastic all the
performances were great it'll be a fun
movie to re-watch even if you know the
plot like I feel like the best Marvel
films are the ones that you're able to
re-watch multiple times because even if
you know the plot it's just so fun to
watch the characters on screen Robert
Downey jr. has that special charisma
that you just instantly forgive most of
the faults in all the Iron Man films in
a lot of the same is true for guardians
of the galaxy to Kurt Russell is an
amazing villain in the movie and even
though I don't always like the movies
that he's in I always like what he does
in each of his movies the trailers have
not done him justice he gets vicious in
this felt my real big ego complaint is
in that you don't learn too much about
his backstory other than he has this
grand plan he wants to replace all life
with him like he's literally just
terraforming the entire universe into
more ego the Living Planet but beyond
that he's a little underserved for
someone that's so big in the cosmic
sense he's supposed to be a celestial in
this movie you would think that he'd be
a much bigger thing but James empties
that they spent a lot of time setting
his character up he's an important part
of the Marvel Universe I suppose there
are ways that he could always come back
in the future is opposed the characters
like yondu who sacrificed himself Han
Solo style or the original way that
Harrison Ford wanted Han Solo to die
redeeming himself while at the same time
going out in a blaze of glory a literal
blaze of glory there is a certain sense
of disappointment in that it's not quite
as connected or overlapping with thor
ragnarok or the other Marvel films as
you would like you have that certain
expectation of Marvel films but I think
that's also in service of trying to keep
it relatively self-contained so even
though they don't hijack this movie with
a bunch of other stuff there is the
sense that something is missing in that
you don't see other big characters pop
up in a plot based way teeing up big
events that are happening next like
post-credit style
so yes the Grand Master does show up so
that's the connection because we will
see him in that movie it's not
as big as other post-credit scenes that
you've seen before like the Doctor
Strange thor ragnarok post-credits scene
so bit of a thumbs down on that so
overall I'll give the film a B+ almost
an a-minus it just dragged down a little
bit by some of the comedy that doesn't
land and it really does lean on the
comedy so it's an amazing film
definitely go see it and let me know
what you guys thought of it if you have
and then we have to talk about the
special thing that is Stanley in this
movie so like I said it's meant to be a
small movie relatively plotless but they
do really big things introduce really
big concepts so because of the big
Stanley twist we now have a unifying
theory of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and of all Stanley Marvel cameos so
you'll probably see that video in a
couple more days like my post credit
scene videos in my guardians 3 video and
what's going to happen later tonight is
there's going to be a new Wonder Woman
trailer so that'll be my next video
should post a couple hours but while you
wait for that you can click here for my
new infinity war video talking about
Captain America's timeline and you can
click here for a brand new flash thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you